on monday the nation will observe
memorial day a sacred day to honor those
who have made the ultimate sacrifice in
honor of this country ahead of this
important day fox news digital spoke to
tom satterly an army veteran who served
during the battle of mogadishu which was
portrayed in the film black hawk down
where 18 american soldiers lost their
lives here's tom reflecting on that
fateful day
we went to mogadishu somalia to try to
stop a warlord mohammed farah hassan a
deed from starving millions of people to
death early on then it started to heat
it up and then one helicopter gets shot
down and i saw it falling overhead you
could hear it crash off in the distance
but we just
everything changed you know everything
changed it was now a rescue mission and
we went on foot the secondary element
went on foot to the crash site to secure
it and try to you know save lives and
recover the bodies that didn't make it
and that's when they penned us down
that feeling of being trapped
and you just want to go home
like i want this to be over
and that's when you realize it's real
combat
you can't just go home
and they don't want you to go home they
want you dead right there
if you can imagine thousands of people
that want you dead it's just the most
horrifying thing you've ever been
through
wow now after a career in the special
forces tom experienced severe ptsd that
even led to thoughts of suicide his life
was saved by the love of his uh life his
wife jen and together they created the
all secure foundation to help his fellow
veterans heal from the trauma of war and
i'm honored to have tom and jen join me
right now uh great to meet both of you
and i have to say especially we know
memorial day is for those who did not
make it home but but tom we live in a
world now with with war and with medical
help and with flight where we are
surviving our troops you can go there
you can get severely injured you survive
and we're able to bring you home or even
with the ieds and everything so we have
more of our troops coming home
who in world war ii would have would
have died on the scene
leaving us with individuals who've had
uh
inexplicable and usually unknowable
experiences that we never would have had
before
this is i think what really we're now
dealing with here in the country and
what your foundation addresses
absolutely tammy thank you for having us
on it's it's
we used to call the invisible wounds of
war but now we know you can conduct
brain scans and it's no longer an
invisible wound it's actually an injury
that can be treated so there is hope for
many people out there that typically
would think this is a life sentence
you know jen uh you know we're seeing a
lot it's been a difficult week for the
country with everything we're dealing
with but one thing we've seen uh well
for years now is that it is women
who begin to make the difference who are
working in partnerships with their
husbands with their loved ones with
their families defending their children
looking to the future uh when you saved
your husband's life and you started up
this business to save more people was
was this something you imagined doing is
this something that came natural for you
or was it was it kind of difficult and a
surprise
i think it's both i
you know i started serving alongside tom
in special operations
as a camera and film person and got a
really inside look and once i started
learning about the epidemic of the
suicides that were plaguing this
community i just couldn't turn the other
way so i don't think that this was
something that i grew up dreaming about
but i'm certainly glad that i'm here and
honored to be here well you know god has
a funny way of of having a plan for us
right what's he the little adage of like
we make plans and god laughs
right i mean this is and this is you
know it's about following
you know our path even though it's one
we could not have imagined so what does
your foundation do we know we're we're
beginning to understand ptsd just that
it exists and now we have to understand
how do we help what is what does your
foundation do exactly and what do you
see is
really the great approach the best
approach to help our our wounded
warriors
so all secure foundations serve special
operations active duty and veterans not
only the warrior but the entire family
and healing from that war trauma and
that could be many different things
every single individual is different so
the approach to healing from pts is very
individual in our foundation we look at
it that way it's an individual injury
and it's something that absolutely can
be healed from and how how do they and
tom are you involved in
working with the individuals and the
families are both of you involved in
this do you have volunteers who who is
part of the team that makes this work
for the people coming to you for help we
consider ourselves the lighthouse we
share our story we share that we share
our modalities of healing that i've gone
through to let everybody else know it's
not as scary as it looks
and then we pass things along and share
it but we have um coaches that are
licensed clinical social workers that
actually do the healing and the help
work all right great well all through
this conversation we've had on the
screen allsecurefoundation.org
thank you both very much have a good
memorial day weekend hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else